Okay. What I'd like to do here is work out what the general rule is.
Imagine that we've got some node and say it's numbered i.
What can we figure out about the parent number of i and the two child numbers of i?
The child numbers are actually quite easy if you look at them.
It's always the node number doubled plus 1.
That's the left child and the right child is adjacent to it so that is 2i+2.
And we can work out from this what the number for the parent ought to be.
All we need to do is subtract one from i and have it.
And in Python that will actually cause it to get rounded down,
but in Math symbols we'll just write a little floor here.
Let's just double check that. Node 6 , 6-1=5.
Half of 5 is 2-1/2 rounded down is 2. 5-1 is 4. Half of that is 2. We don't have to round it.
Both 5 and 6 have the parent of 2. Coming up the other way, 2 doubled plus 1 is 5.
2 doubled plus 2 is 6 so that gives us this kind of local structure
and this is repeated throughout.
Therefore we could use this to try to figure out what the right child of 72 would be.
It's 72 doubled, which is 144, plus 2, which is 146.